لقي ثمانيه اشخاص على الاقل مصرعهم في
ايطاليا واليونان كما سجلت خسائر ماديه
فادحه جراء حرائق الغابات التي ضربت دولا
اوروبيه بينها اسبانيا وايطاليا وفرنسا
واليونان وسلوفينيا والبرتغال وقد فاقم
الارتفاع القياسي في درجات الحراره خطر
حرائق الغابات في اوروبا التي تعاني بعض
دولا اصلا مشاكل واضطرابات اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى قدره الحكومات
الاوروبيه على التعامل مع تداعيات الكلفه
الفادحه لحرائق الغابات وكيف ستنعكس هذه
الحرائق وتبعاتها على واقع القاره ودورها
والى اي حد يمكن ان تفاقم الخسائر
المترتبه على هذه الحرائق تركيز القاره
على الامن الاقتصادي كاولويه قصوى وما فرص
تعزيز دورها العالمي من خلال هذه المقاربه
وما هي الاستراتيجيه التي يمكن ان تلجا
اليها اوروبا لمواجهه تحدياتها الامنيه
والمناخيه والجيوسيه وما مدى ارتباط هذه
التحديات بتصاعد اليمين الشعبوي فيها
[موسيقى]
بثلاثه قتله في اليونان بينهم طياران
لقياحتفهما افراس سقوط طائرتهما في خضم
جهود اطفاء حرائق الغابات المستمره في
البلاد منذ اكثر من اسبوع ترتفع الخسائر
في الارواح جراء هذه الحرائق واثار التغير
المناخي الاخرى في اوروبا الى ثمانيه على
الاقل بعد مصرع خمسه اخرين في ايطاليا وقد
اجتاحت الحرائق عددا من دول القاره العجوز
بينها اسبانيا وايطاليا وفرنسا واليونان
وسلوفينيا والبرتغال خسائر ماديه فادحه
مباشره وغير مباشره سببتها حرائق الغابات
في اوروبا التي عانت دول عديده منها خلال
الفتره الماضيه اضطرابات اجتماعيه سياسيه
واقتصاديه نتيجه مصاعب اقتصاديه تنوعت
اسبابها بين دوله واخرى
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من برلين
الدكتوره نجاه عبد الحق الخبيره
الاقتصاديه والباحثه المختصه في شؤون
الاوروبيه ومن جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه جنيف مرحبا
بكما دكتوره نجاه تبدا معك عدد من دول
اوروبا كانت هي في الاساس تعاني من
اضطرابات سياسيه واجتماعيه نتيجه
خلفيه اقتصاديه الى اي حد هذه الحرائق
تزيد هذه الحمول على الحمولات على
الحكومات التي عانت من هذه التبعات
للمشاكل الاقتصاديه
مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا بك بضيفنا الكريم
والمشاهدين الكرام نعم هذه الحرائق هي جزء
من ازمه اخرى تنضم الى الازمات الموجوده
في اوروبا حاليا وهي ممكن نسميها ازمه
المناخ او ازمه التغير المناخي والتي تؤدي
الى ارتفاع تكاليف الدوله للحفاظ على اولا
انقاذ الارواح
انقاذ الاراضي ومن ثم معالجه هذه الاماكن
التي اصيبت بالحرائق يعني العديد من القرى
وبعض المدن في دول في مناطق مختلف من
اوروبا تم اجلائها وكل هذول هؤلاء الاشخاص
يتوقعون من الحكومات دعمهم اما بالاستقرار
باماكن جديده او ايضا بالرجوع الى بيوتهم
كل ذلك يزيد الاعباء على الحكومات على
المصاريف الحكوميه التي الان بشكل عام
باوروبا يبدا تقليصها بسبب خاصه ازمه
الطاقه التي ادت الى ازمه اقتصاديه وبسبب
التضخم اي ان الثمن الذي يدفعه المواطنون
ايضا مرتفع هنا والسؤال ايضا الى اي حتى
تستطيع الدول الاستمرار
بمكافحه الحرائق يعني قد يكون هذا العام
جيدا ولكن ماذا عن الاعوام القادمه لانه
عاده الفرق المختصه هي فرق الحالات
الطوارئ حالات الطوارئ قد تدوم اسبوع
اسبوعان ولكنها اذا دامت اكثر واذا كانت
باستمرار اكثر طبعا هناك تراكم خبره ولكن
هناك تكاليف اخرى يجب زياده عدد
الاشخاص الذين يعملون يجب زياده المعدات
يجب وجود طائرات والى اخره لذلك فعلا هذه
الازمه تضيف من الازمات الموجوده الان في
اوروبا
وللاسف اسبابها متراكمه ليست وليده اليوم
او الامس القرارات تؤخذ عاده في هذه
الحالات في ما يسمى انفل يعني على مستوى
البلديات او المجالس المحليه وليس
بالضروره على مستوى الحكومات لانه كل
منطقه تعرف
ما هي احتياجاتها وهذه الاماكن اذا كانت
ليست كبيره وفقيره بعد الشيء امكانياته
محدوده هناك جانب اخر اود ان اشير اليها
ايضا هو السياحه خاصه السواح من شمال
اوروبا يعني يفضلون جنوب اوروبا وتونس
مثلا ومصر ولكن على الاخص تونس وجنوب
اوروبا ايطاليا اسبانيا البرتغال واليونان
وجنوب تركيا هي مناطق سياحيه مفضله هناك
صناعه ضخمه جدا خلف ذلك وهذا سيتاثر بشكل
كبير جدا لان ايضا علينا ان نفكر بان كل
تامينات السفر والتعويضات يجب ان يعوضها
احدهم اذا اضطر المسافرون او السواح قطع
اجازاتهم كل ذلك يعني هذه قد تكون تكاليف
ليست مباشره الان ولكن في الفتره القادمه
ستكون خسائر وتكاليف غير مباشره ستؤثر
فعلا على القطاع السياحي على قطاع
التامينات وايضا بالعموم على الوضع
الاقتصادي لان هناك تكالي عاليه للحكومات
ايضا الدعم من الاتحاد الاوروبي قضيه لا
يكون الى الابد لهذه الدول في حاله
الطوارئ نحن امام ازمه لم تعدها اوروبا
يعني هذه الحرائق هي ضربت دولا دون اخرى
ولكن اذا ما اردنا الحديث سيد حسني عن
الاثار الاقتصاديه لهذه الحرائق الى اي حد
ممكن ان تمتد لتطال هذا الفضاء الاوروبي
المرتبط سياسيا واقتصاديا عبر الياته
وحتى ايطاليا ليست لديها قدره كافيه ليس
لديها مثل اسطول كافي لبعض الطائرات
المخصصه لمكافحه الحرائق لا يمكن في
النهايه بوحدها دون مساعده ما يسمى
بالاليه الاوروبيه في الاداره الازمات ان
تعالج هذه القضاء هذه المشاكل وهو ما نرى
اليوم مثلا في جنوب ايطاليا نقطه اخيره هي
اعتقد كذلك بالنسبه للدول الاوروبيه لحد
الساعه لم تستطيع فعلا على وضع على وضع
ميكانيزمات متفق عليها صحيح ان في النهايه
الحرائق تسمح قضيه هي قضيه محليه لكن في
نفس الوقت يحاول الدول الاوروبيه منذ منذ
تقريبا خمس سنوات ان تضع استراتيجيه مشترك
لكل الدول الاوروبيه يكون هناك تضامن داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن من الصعب وضع هذه
باعتبار ان هناك قبل كل شيء قضيه سياديه
ثم كذلك دور الكبير التي الذي تقوم به
البلديات في هذا الموضوع
تاثير هذه الحرائق ربما اقتصاديا على هذه
الدول لنقرا
اكثر
استراتيجي للدول الاوروبيه نلاحظ بان كانت
هناك رؤيه وتصورات لدى المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ركزت فيها على الامن الاقتصادي الاوروبي
كاولويه قصوى ما مدى هنا قدره سيده نجاه
الحكومات الاوروبيه على تحقيق مثل هذا هذا
التصور وانجازات ضمن هذا التصور ضمن
تحديات
جيوسياسيه كالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وايضا التوتر مع الصين والتنافسيه ايضا
معها في المجال والفضاء الاقتصادي ايضا
بالاضافه الى تبعات هذه الكوارث الطبيعيه
نعم يعني مثل ما ذكر الاستاذ على
ذلك بان اوروبا لم تتمكن من الوصول الى
سياسه او استراتيجيه موحده لعلاج الازمات
ذلك يعني ان مثلا الان ايطاليا في ازمه
كبيره هناك دعم من الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى
ولكن ليس هناك اتفاق وذلك ينعكس ايضا على
موضوع الامن الاقتصادي يعني ازمه المناخ
تاثيرها على البلديات تاثيرها على الثروه
الزراعيه الثروه الحيوانيه واقطع السياحه
سيكون كبير جدا وكل ذلك على الاغلب يعني
انا حاولت ان ابحث ما مدى يعني شمول ذلك
بكل الاقتصادي وهو على الهامش اي ان ايضا
الدول الاوروبيه كاتحاد اوروبي مجتمعه
والدول السياديه نفسها لم تعطي امكانيه
ازمات بيئيه الوزن الكافي للتحضير لها
اولا ولمكافحها لمكافحتها ثانيا وايضا
الجاهزيه ما يخص الاساطير والمعدات
والطائرات لانها ايضا ومعدات خاصه ومكلفه
جدا كل ذلك على الاغلب يعني الان الحرائق
الان دائره ونامل ان ينجو جميع الاشخاص
وان يتمكنوا من اخمادها ولكن ماذا بعد ذلك
فعلا سيؤثر ذلك ايضا على الاغلب ان تكون
هناك مناطق غير قابله للسكن بعد ذلك لعده
سنوات وذلك سيؤثر على كل الاداء الاقتصادي
لهذه المنطقه وهذه تراكميه هذه الاحداث
ستؤثر على الامن الاقتصادي الاوروبي وايضا
على الامن السياسي الاوروبي يعني هذه ازمه
لم يتم الاعداد لها جيدا يعني كانت
بالحسبان ولكن الخلاف كان اكثر هل هذا
تغير مناخي بسبب الانبعاثات ام هذا تغير
طبيعي
طالما الدول غير متاثره دعني اقول السويد
مثلا او حتى المانيا لغايه الان لا تشعر
بحجم هذه الازمه ولا ترى ضروره لاتباعها
في ميزانياتها مثلا ولكن اعتقد ان هذا
تصرف خاطئ لان اذا وصلت درجات الحراره في
اليونان درجه وهو شيء استثنائي جدا ووصلت
في برلين الى 32 قد تصل في برلين العام
القادم او بعد عامين الى 36 اذا ثم ستصبح
40 مثلا لا يعني هناك ازمه جديده لم ازمه
جديده ولم تستعد وهنا سيد حسني انشغال
اوروبا بمعالجه ازماتها
الاقتصاديه وما يترتب على ذلك من ازمات
اجتماعيه تؤثر ايضا على المنظور السياسي
لهذه الحكومات الى اي حدث بموجه نظرك
سيؤثر على دورها
العالمي وسيعزز ربما انكفائها بمشاكلها
الداخليه
الدول الاوروبيه هي مهتمه بقضيه قضيه
اقتصاد بقضيه الامن الاقتصاد كما تعلمين
يعني اوروبا يعني هي دائما هناك قاطره
وقاتله الاوروبيه كانت ما بين بريطانيا
وفرنسا الان هي المانيا وفرنسا ولا يوجد
هناك اتفاق بين المانيا وفرنسا للاسف
ليسوا ليست على قلب واحد ولذلك هناك
العديد من الان من انشقاقات او ليبقى لنقل
الاختلافات حول قضيه الامن الاوروبي حول
قضيه استقلاليا الاوروبيه
من سواء من الحلف الاطلسي او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اكتشفت اوروبا بانها في
النهايه هشه عندما عندما اصبحت تستورد
الكمامات من من الصين عندما لم تستطع
قادره كذلك على انتاج اللقاحات الكافيه في
ازمه الكوفيد وبدات فعلا في قضيه التصنيع
الداخلي والامن الامن الاقتصادي الداخلي
لكن في نفس الوقت اصطدمت بتداخل الاقتصاد
بان في النهايه من الصعب جدا ان تكون
تكلفه اقل من التكلفه في الصين وان هناك
مقاومه داخليه ثم اكتشفت كذلك بان هناك
ارتباط مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
قضيه الامن الصناعي فنعم نتفق معك يعني
سؤال في سؤالك هو ان من الصعب جدا على
اوروبا في النهايه ان تفتح مسارات عده
مسارات في ال واحد وتفتح جبهات المتعدده
في ان واحد قضيه الامن الاقتصادي كذلك فك
الارتباط مع الصين وهو ما تحاول الولايات
المتحده فرضه الان على الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انت كذلك ان يكون لديها دور دور
اساسي في الحرب على اوكرانيا من خلال من
خلال الدفع بميزانيات كبرى لتسليح
اوكرانيا من الصعب على اوروبا في النهايه
انت في بكل هذه الشروط ولذلك انا اتقدم
تكون هناك اولويات داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
اوروبا وصلت الى ما وصلت اليه مع اقتصاديا
لانها في النهايه كانت تعتمد عسكريا
وامنيا على الولايات المتحده كان الحلف في
الاطلسي وامريكا هي المظله الامنيه التي
التي مكنت اوروبا في النهايه بالانشغال
اقتصاديه قضايا الرفاه الاقتصاديه التعليم
البيئه الى غير ذلك الان الولايات المتحده
تريد تريد ان تشرك اوروبا في العبء المالي
لهذا لهذا لهذا التامين ان صح التعبير
العسكري وهذا سيكون ستكون لديه يعني اكيد
نتائج على القطاعات الاخرى الصحيه
والاجتماعيه والبيئيه
سينقلني ايضا كل هذا الذي تحدث عنه
الدكتور حسني سيده نجاه الى اي درجه مثل
هذه الهشاشه ربما الاقتصاديه
نتيجه هذه المشاكل المتراكمه منذ فتره
كورونا
تسعه عشر تضاف اليها التضخم الناجم عن
الحرب والازمات ازمه الغاز التي عاشتها
اوروبا وايضا الكلف الامنيه
الكبيره للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ستطرح
تحديات على هذه التصورات الاوروبيه
المطروحه للامن الاقتصادي
يعني منذ بدات الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
كانت احد المقولات ان ما قبل ربع والعشرين
من فبراير الشباط هو ليس ما بعده وفعلا
كان هذا يوم تغيرت فيه كل المعدلات
السياسيه السياسيه والاقتصاديه ومعدلات
الطاقه في اوروبا وادى الى تغييرات كبيره
يعني
التوقعات التي يعني بدات تنتصر يوم امس
وصباح اليوم حول النمو الاقتصادي للربع
الثاني من هذا العام لا تبشر خيرا هي ليست
سيئه جدا يعني ليس سيناريو اسود جدا
ولكنها لا تبشر خيرا بمعنى ان هذا الربع
الثاني على التوالي في منطقه اليورو الذي
لا يوجد فيه نمو اقتصادي على الاقل
المدرسه الاقتصاديه التي تعتبر النمو
الاقتصادي هو المؤشر الوحيد حول كيف صحه
الاقتصاد لانه هناك ايضا مدارس مختلفه
ولكن على الاقل هي المدرسه السائده يعني
تعطينا اثباتات بانه هناك
ركود قد ياتي قريبا اذا لم تحصل تغيرات
يعني وايضا التحكم
بالتضخم الذي حصل في منطقه اليورو على
الرغم من استخدام اليات رفع الفوائد لم
تتم السيطره عليه بعد بعض الدول تعافت
ولكن بعضها لم يتعافى بعد ومنها المانيا
على سبيل المثال لذلك ان ماءات ما يخص
الاقتصاد خاصه
للاسف لا ارى اي تفاؤل كبير لان الوضع ليس
جيدا الان قد تبدو مساله الحرائق مساله
صغيره مساله موجوده في مناطق معينه قد لا
تؤدي الى اضرار كبيره جدا الان ولكن
التراكم الازمات الصغيره في المناطق
المختلفه سيؤدي الى يعني كما نقول
تضعضعات اجتماعيه التي ستضغط على السياسه
وذلك سيبعثر كل الاوراق والمخطط الموجوده
للسيا يعني لا اريد ان اعطي وزنا اكبر
للحرائق ولكن لا يجب التعامل معها
باستهانه لانه قد يكون لها اثار الى
تراكمات للمشاكل التي يعاني منها تعاني
منها هذه الكتله الاوروبيه ولكن جمله
التحديات هذا يقودنا لسؤال دكتور حسني انه
جمله التحديات الاقتصاديه لاي درجه ستشكل
معضله لاوروبا في استخدام الاقتصاد
لمحاوله اعاده التموضع الدولي ضمن توازنات
القوى المتغيره
يعني ضمن هذه التوازنات تؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار الولايات المتحده الصين الداخله
بقوه ضمن هذه التوازنات توازنات القوى
الدوليه
وروسيا وغيرها
من المؤكد ان تراكم هذه الازمات والعب
الذي في النهايه التي تسببه على
الميزانيات
الوطنيه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ستعيق من
طموح العديد من الدول الاوروبيه الى احد
الساعه يعني المقاربه دائما هو ان هناك
فصل ما بين السياسات الداخليه والسياسات
الخارجيه ورغم تعدد القضايا او نقول
التحديات الداخليه يبقى لاوروبا هامش من
الحركه دوليا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تريد دائما اعطاء فرصه خاصه لدول مهمه مثل
فرنسا وكذلك المانيا وحتى بعض الدول
الاطلسيه اخرى للعب دور مهم جدا تجاه
الصين ثم كذلك الحرب الاوكرانيه لكن
الاخطر من ذلك اعتقد هو اذا كان هناك اذا
كانت هذه التراكمات الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه تسبب فعلا عدم الاستقرار داخل
المنظومه الحاكمه يعني داخل الحكومات
الانذار الاخير جاء من اسبانيا يعني راينا
ان اليمين المتطرف لم يصل الى ما يريده
اصبح قوه سياسيه مهمه يمكن ان تصنع فعلا
من يحكم اسبانيا في المانيا راعينا كذلك
التقدم الكبير
المتطرف فرنسا كذلك نرى جيدا الموقع
في هولندا وستكون الانتخابات المقبله 202
انتخابات الاوروبيه كذلك معيار مهم لقياس
مدى تقدم هذا اليمين الذي يتغذى في
النهايه بخطاب شعبوي يدور حول عجز
الحكومات الحاليه اوروبيا نتيجه ربما
تقاربها اللاموط مع الولايات المتحده
نتيجه انخراطها في مشروع لا يعبر عن الراي
العام بصفه عامه نتيجه كذلك الصراع مع
روسيا هذا يؤثر جدا في الحملات الانتخابيه
ويؤثر كذلك في ضعف الاداء الحكومي داخليا
وربما كذلك حتى على المستوى الدولي
هذه نقطه مهمه طرحها السيد حسني بان صعود
اليمين الشعبويه في اوروبا
حتى تجليات هذه الازمات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي عانت منها مجموعه من
الدول الاوروبيه الى اي درجه سيعزز مثل
هذا
الانزياح نحو اليمين في الدول الاوروبيه
ام انه ربما قد يعيد ربما مره اخرى
هذا المسار وهذا المؤشر الى حاله يعني وسط
اقرب الى الوسط وليس اليمين
يعني ما ذكره الدكتور انه يؤيده تماما ان
المؤشرات فرنسا
سابقا اسبانيا المانيا في بعض الولايات او
على مستوى البلديات هناك توجه الى اليمين
يعني خاصه المانيا الدوله التي كانت تعتبر
نفسها لعقود طويله ان عندها مناعه ضد
اليمين بسبب تاريخها الان
حركات بافكار فاشيه وعنصريه يعني
تقترب الى مراكز الحكم
والاستطلاعات الراي يعني مع انه لا يوجد
انتخابات ولكن يوجد استطلاعات رايي دوريه
الاخيره اثبتت ان الحزب اليمين المتطرف ما
يسمى بحزب البديل الاي اف دي وصل الى اكبر
حزب معارضه وهو حزب المسيحي المحافظ الذي
هو حزب المستشفى السابقه ماركل وهذا فعلا
ينظر خطرا بان هذه الاحزاب الاحزاب التي
كانت تعتبر هامشيه على طرف السياسيه وليس
في صلبها تحولت الان شيئا فشيء بسبب هذه
الازمات وبسبب تعطش الجماهير الى حلول
سريعه يعني هي ازمه اليمين بانه يعطي
اجابات سهله على ازمات اعمى مثلا ازمه
الطاقه في المانيا دوله كانت تعتمد لعقود
على الغاز الروسي الرخيص وان قطع يعني لو
كان ذلك ماء او خبزا طبعا ستنشا از فما
بالك بالغاز ارتفاع الاسعار فحسب اليمين
يحاول يعطي حلول سريعه اذا هو معظم
الناخبين يتوجهون اليه لانهم فقدوا
الثقافي الحكومه او الاحزاب الحاليه ذلك
فعلا يعني اوروبا تتوجه الى نحو اليمين
اذا هذا هو رايك نعم ولكن السؤال الى اي
يمين ومتى ممكن ايقافه او تباطؤ تقدمه هذا
ما ستثبته السنوات القادمه يعني وضمن هذا
المعنيه مثل ما نقول يعني سانتي من
الخساره كان ولكن ذلك يعني بعد اربع سنوات
انه ممكن ان يتغير وهذا المعطى الجديد
يضاف الى المعطيات الاخرى دكتور حسني ما
هي فرص هنا الدول الاوروبيه في صياغه رؤيه
موحده لمواجهه كل هذه التحديات
الفرص ما زالت يعني متاحه بالنسبه للاتحاد
الاوروبي يعني يعني رغم كل الصعاب الاتحاد
الاوروبي ما زال واقفا يعني هناك تخصيص
لميزانيات كبرى خاصه مثلا في ازمه كورونا
كما رايته الان كذلك في الحرائق لكن انا
اعتقد ان قوه الاتحاد الاوروبي من قوه
الدول التي ترفع التي تقود هذا الاتحاد
الاوروبي اذا وصل الرئيس الى الى اتفاق او
الى قناه على ان هناك ما زالت الى حد الان
خلافات بين الرجلين فيمكن وسببها ليس
داخليا بما هو اكثر ما هو خارجيا القضايا
الخارجيه زادت تكلفه الخلافات الد
اخليه ان يتجنب قضيه قضيه اليمين الشعبوي
الذي ليس لديه حلول وانما هو فقط يريد
يقول بان هناك مشاكل دون ان يقترح حلول
فنعتقد فعلا الاتحاد الاوروبي يمكن ان
ينهض من هذه الازمه بشرط ان يكون هناك
فعلا يعني توافق ما بين الدول الاساسيه
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي شكرا جزيلا لك من
جنيف الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه جنيف واشكر ايضا من برلين
ضيفتنا دكتوره نجاه عبد الحق الخبيره
الاقتصاديه والباحثه المختصه في الشؤون
الاوروبيه شكرا جزيلا لكما الى هنا تنتهي
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]